This is a true silver module.
When you receive this item, make sure the switch is in the up position.
There are more detailed instructions also in your F-122 manual.
Now on the back here you're going to see there's your cord that plugs into the iron output
right here into the F-122 and then you'll see this here.
This is where the jar plugs in so I've got the jar setting back here.
You'll see the jar here.
I've got my water loaded to still water by a good quality to still water and only fill to
the line on the jar.
I'm plugging this in next.
So now I've got the jar plugged in, I've got the water loaded.
I've tightened the cap.
You'll see the probes inside here and those are pharmaceutical grade silver, 0.9999 grade
silver.
I'm a very clean product that you'll be making here with our silver maker and at that
point all we need to do is we need to actually access the program and I will show you which
program I would recommend.
So we're going to be making anywhere from say 6 to 10 parts per million silver and some
people say well I want to make a higher PPM silver, I don't recommend that.
I do recommend making what we are telling you to make because if someone drank this whole
jar the worst they'll get as a stomach ache at 10 PPM.
If you want to take a higher parts per million silver instead of taking two ounces a day just
double it or triple it.
You're making this stuff for pennies anyway.
So it's not costing you $10 an ounce, it's probably costing you two cents an ounce to make
this.
So by the way our probes, if you wear them out you'd have to be selling gallons and gallons
of this stuff.
So these should last you a lifetime, there's an entire one ounce of silver in here, a solid
silver here so this should last you a lifetime, okay?
So we're going to access the program next.
So we have the True Ripe Standard Edition version 5 software open here, you'll see it with
the display, the True Silver module once you're in the True Silver program.
Now if I click open home here, you go down the list.
You'll find True Silver here's the folder.
I will open that up.
The program you want to pick is this one right here, Accelerator 32 ounce production 2 and
this will take six hours and 15 minutes, it'll generate roughly 8 to 12 parts per million
of silver.
Now one of the added mention, make sure you heat up your water to about 80 degrees or higher.
I frankly put this jar without the silver probes in and just a water and a microwave for say
about three minutes and it gets the water nice and warm and you'll generate a quicker
production that way.
So all right, at that point all we have to do is click run and we'll be generating silver
for the next six hours when the program's finished, we'll check for the tindle effect.
I'll show you that next.
Now as you look at the jar here, we have produced our silver to make sure that you generate
the silver, you take your red LED and it's called the tindle effect and you darken the
room and you just spray the LED through.
If the silver has been produced, you'll get a thin line right through the water.
If not, we would recommend rerunning the program for another three to six hours because there
are times of year that it takes just a little longer to get a good process.
And if you see that line, it is, it is ready and once again, make sure you do this in a light